Bremsstellung bzw. Bremshaltung.
Ich muss mich da korrigieren. Bremshaltung.
Die Bremse kann man auf verschiedene Art und Weisen halten.
Bisher, und das ist auch in Ordnung so, könnt ihr auch mal da bleiben,
bisher habt ihr die Bremse am Steg in der Hand behalten.
So, und habt Kurven aus dem Bereich beflogen.
Das ist völlig in Ordnung.
Jetzt ist es aber so, die Bremse hat 10-12 cm Vorlauf, manchmal auch 15 cm,
und diesen Vorlauf brauchen wir für den Beschleunigen.
Sobald wir beschleunigen, haben wir die Kappe nach vorne unten geneigt,
und hinten die Hinterkante etwas höher.
Und wenn wir geradeaus fliegen, und ihr schaut mal nach oben,
dann ist unsere Bremse so nach hinten ausbauchend.
Macht so einen richtigen Bogen, und das muss sein, oder?
Weil sobald wir nämlich den beschleunigten Flug haben, ist dann die Bremse hinten gespannt.
Und die Bremse dürfen wir aus dem Grund nicht ziehen, im beschleunigten Flug.
Denn wenn wir jetzt noch zusätzlich die Bremse ziehen,
erzeugt das in dem Moment hier kurzzeitig mehr Auftrieb,
und der Schirm könnte frontal einklappen.
Einseitig einklappen, so genau kann man es auch nicht sagen.
Auf jeden Fall Einklappgefahr deutlich erhöht,
und aus dem Grund tut man nicht mehr steuern im beschleunigten Flug.
Also könnt ihr da ganz leicht an den Hintern mitsteuern.
Jetzt habt ihr bisher die Bremse so am Steg in der Hand behalten.
Und das ist aber gerade beim Thermikfliegen oft das Problem,
dass man mit den Bremsen irgendwo da unten ziemlich tief arbeiten muss.
Bei starker Thermik muss man auch mal stärker bremsen.
Das heißt, da ist dann der Arbeitsbereich über längeren Zeitraum sehr, sehr kraftaufwendig.
Und deshalb gehen viele Piloten hin und verkürzen,
sozusagen, diesen Bremsweg, indem sie die Bremse anders halten.
Wir haben den sogenannten Franzosengriff.
Die Franzosen gehen dort oft, nicht alle, aber viele gehen durch den Bremsgriff durch
und halten jetzt diese Leine, Bremsleine,
halten diese Bremsleine zwischen Zeigefinger und Daumen.
Man hat durch das ein sehr gutes Gespür.
Man hat die Bremse auch ein bisschen verkürzt.
Nicht mehr ganz da unten, sondern vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen da oben.
Also schon mal etwas angenehmer, mehr Gespür.
Aber der große Nachteil an dem ist, und deshalb auf gar keinen Fall bei mir anwenden,
wir kommen vermutlich sowieso mit dicken Handschuhen nicht mehr aus dem Bremsgriff heraus.
Es gab schon tödliche Vorfälle, war zwar nicht ganz bewiesen,
aber viele Piloten haben bestätigt, dass der Pilot so unterwegs war.
Und sie haben gesehen, dass er nicht
den Notschirm auslösen konnte.
Also könnte es wirklich an dem liegen, dass man da nicht mehr aus dem Bremsgriff heraus.
Das heißt, wenn man das gerne machen möchte, dann kann man das wirklich machen,
indem man einfach den Daumen draußen lässt.
Und so kommt man noch schneller aus diesem Griff heraus.
Die Ungarn, den Ungarangriff, die Ungarn haben dann gesagt,
Moment, das ist uns zu riskant.
Wir wollen aber die Bremsleine trotzdem zwischen Zeigefinger und Daumen behalten.
Und deshalb haben die Ungarn gesagt,
oder sind die Ungarn da zu hingegangen und haben die Bremse einfach so.
So kann man natürlich jederzeit loslassen und den Notschirm greifen.
Aber die Gefahr ist auch größer, dass man die Leine mal wirklich aus Versehen verliert.
Und dann braucht man wieder einen Moment, bis man die gepackt hat.
Von dem her ist jetzt für mich nicht unbedingt eine Variante.
Gefällt mir jetzt nicht persönlich.
Wir gehen dazu her und verkürzen die Bremse wirklich extrem.
Also wir nehmen diese 10 bis 12 cm Leerlauf, die nehmen wir raus,
indem wir die Bremse ganz normal am Steg in der Hand behalten
und so nach außen hin eine sogenannte Wicklung machen.
Seht ihr das? Also ich drehe sie nach außen hin
und jetzt führe ich diese Bremsleine hier so am Handballen vorbei
und kann sie locker zwischen Zeigefinger und Daumen in der Hand behalten.
Ich habe ein sehr gutes Gespür für den Schirm
und habe jetzt einen sehr kurzen Steuerweg.
Das heißt, ich arbeite jetzt nur noch hier
und durch das ist es halt viel weniger kraftaufwendig.
Ich habe eben einen kürzeren Weg, spüre den Schirm besser,
weniger kraftaufwendig und der Vorteil,
ich kann die Wicklung jederzeit wieder rausnehmen.
Oder, wenn ich einen mehr brauche,
nehme ich nochmal einen mehr ein.
Stoll beispielsweise, A-Schirm.
Da muss ich zweimal wickeln.
Also sehr ein großer Vorteil
und für gewisse Manöver auch eine sehr gute Variante.